hello everyone I'm back I didn't think
I'd be doing any videos today since I
just got back from Dubrovnik but I
thought since so many of you have
requested this game well I've been on
vacation I still have an hour before the
game Croatia vs. England the soccer
match of course so I thought best best
to do this game now and then think about
what other videos to show tomorrow
so before we check out the game I do
have some very exciting photos for you
we can also use them as a photo
challenges there haven't been a lot of
photo challenges since I've been away so
let's check it out they're all quite
outstanding they were heard they were
made by God and or a trifle from a reto
photography I will put a lot all of the
hell links to somehow some of their
works in the description below as well
as to the event in question so you can
check out some more photos and some
interesting interviews like an interview
with the event winner winner young upon
me I see and there is also an
interesting interview with a vastly von
Schuch and so on and so on
so you can you know just check out the
photos and try to recognize as many
people as possible so here we have a
nice nice photo there let's check out
another one there you have it now let's
check another one also a very nice photo
and here like I said in my other social
media this is the photo that you know
sets the awesomeness bar for all other
photos so here it is for all of us to
marvel at it very nice and for the for
the real photo challenge for this video
since everything is you know so colorful
and the summer is here who is this who
is the person in this photo so there you
have it to give you a little bit of help
it's it's the 2016 World Chess
Championship challenger riding a big
pink bird so best of luck to everyone
now getting back to our game it's Wesley
so with the white pieces against a
Ramage bubble program Amanda the game
was played in the Leon Masters 2018 and
it was a a four game match so this is a
this is the game from round one and we
do have a couple of photos of this event
here we have a nice photo of Fraggle
before the game also we have a nice
photo of Wesley so let's check it out
sorry about that
Wesley has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 we have Knight to f6 and now
Knight to c3 when you see a move like
Knight to c3 bringing the knight into
the game before actually opening opening
the C pawn even really all the chess
masters like Philidor steinitz will tell
you that this is not the way to play
chess but in modern times anything is
possible and Wesley wants to create
something something new on the board
that will perhaps confuse ya a young
progress this is a rapid event and it's
fair to say that ahead the time this
game was played with the saw was rated
over a hundred kilo points above Prague
I believe Wesley was somewhere around 20
780 and Prague was 16 hundred and
something is it seems like Prague who
never played rapid events for for yellow
points we have d5 Bishop to f4 and now
Bishop to f5 Knights the b5 here Wesley
is going for the c7 pawn and it's been a
while so I forgot to do to reduce the
volume nice to be 5 going after the c7
pawn and now Knight to a6 and by playing
this night to be 5 move Wesley now
against time to move the C pawn first
III we have e 6 and now C for Bishop to
e7 and in game number 3 instead of
Bishop to e7 Prague went for c6 as he
obviously found that it was an
improvement to Bishop to e7 but ok a3 we
have castles c5 now c5 grabbing more
space but kind of neglecting development
so you do have probably black can take
advantage of this but in a rapid game
you know and nothing is simple here
probably goes nice to e8 here ideas like
maybe f6e 5 are possible you know or
trying to overload the the central pawn
as then the C pawn would become a
weakness we have b4 solidifying the
Queen side now comes c6 getting denied
back Knight c3 and now comes Knights to
be a so first 98 and our nights to be
eight you all know you know if I did say
that the hardest move to find is with
the knight back so obviously playing two
moves with the knight back that that
must be something excellent and here we
have G for Wesley starts his King set
expansion and his attack on progress
King Bishop to g6 and now Knight to f3
you want to play h4 although you can't
play h4 immediately both Queen and the
Bishop are guarding h4 so now that
Knight to f3 has been played h4 and h5
is definitely a threat
we have Knight to f6 now attacking the
g4 pawn and now Knight to e5 defending
the g4 pawn but also attacking the
bishop on g6 here the sacrifice would h4
for threatening h5 doesn't really work
because after Knight captures h5 Bishop
can calmly come to a 5 and now h6 will
be met with the g6 and the white didn't
really achieve anything here basically
just blundered upon but okay after
Knight to f6
we have Knight to e5 now defending the
g4 pawn and also attacking the bishop on
g6 Knight F to d7 offering two to trade
nights and here comes Knight captures on
g6 and while here of course most of the
times you want to capture towards the
center as this improves yours
you know central pawn structure but here
Prague who plays F captures on g6 he
opens up his rook on f8 and now it's the
game takes a completely different
character what's the place the bishop to
g3 now preparing ideas like f4 or h4 and
the probably immediately stops this he
plays g5 not allowing f4 or h4 Bishop to
d3 now if this g po never moves then the
bishop is nicely eyeing that age
seven-point Queen to h5 could be an idea
so okay Bishop to f6 prabhu still
continues with his plan as this Knight
to d7 was played a five is the move
Prager wants to play
we have h4 here pawn captures on h4 and
now comes Bishop to d6 so okay a
temporary pawn sacrifice by Wesley he
attacks the rook on f8 and this is this
was Wesley's idea he thought after
Bishop after Roe comes to f7 his idea
was g5 attacking the bishop
after captures now queen g4 complete
mobilizations for the price of two
points king e2 is coming the other
rookies coming to g1 so this would be
this would be an excellent attack by
Wesley but here Prabhu isn't interested
in material he goes for the old old
morphe idea you know development ahead
of material and he decides to sacrifice
the exchange he plays d5 and here okay
you can capture the rook immediately if
you play better captures Knight captures
and then after pawn captures Bishop
captures you can play Queen b3 defend
the knight on c3 and after a five the
game continues white can white won't
really be safe either on the Queen side
or on the King side but you know here's
of the exchange but it's it's not very
pleasant for white so instead after E 5
ways to plays the correct idea he plays
g5 sacrifices yet another pawn Bishop
captures on g5 and this is where Wesley
goes wrong he plays Queen h5 immediately
threatening of course Bishop captures on
h7 but instead he should have went for D
captures on e5 and now you really see
the problem now the rook is still under
attack and now you can't even play rook
to f7 because then a six will be a
terrible threat so now you have to
continue with something like g6 where
then white can either continue with the
attack would therefore wife can even
capture the rook but if you try to save
the rook then Queen to h5 will be a
terrible threat after you defend this
Bishop to h6 another thing comes rogue
do you want the threat now is of course
Queen captures after Marshall blocks the
Bishop f5 and now black will lose the
lose the exchange and the white will
have a much better position C captures
and again this is this is a threat you
have to move the king and now this this
is coming and this is only one line that
shows how how much better white is here
but here was the wind for the immediate
Queen to h5 and okay I'm sure he saw
what was coming Prabhu immediately went
for e4 which is of course the strongest
move and the worst one for Knight
captures on e4 pawn captures so a piece
sacrifice and now Bishop the c-4 check
King moves and now comes
captors on a fade quicker first g6 not
capturing immediately kicking the Queen
back Queen to g4 and now comes Knight
captures and I faith Queen captures only
4/10 Queen to e7 Prague now immediately
offers a trade of Queen's Queen captures
Bishop captures and now King - E -
Wesley brings the King into the game and
prepares to bring the rook into the game
and what's what's the standing now after
her after all is said and done here if
you count the pawns it's six points
black six points white but one thing you
can see is that Prague has a bishop and
the night for Wesley's rook so however
you put this black is better here g5 we
have rook a to be one a six now
preventing b5 d5 now pawn captures
Bishop captures and Knight to c6 I would
have looked at e1 rook to b8 now the
knight can move as the b7 ponies will no
longer be attacked from the bishop
bishop to e4 and now King to g8 working
to g7 b 5 now pawn captures rook
captures and here knife to a7 Praga
finds a way to simplify ro captures rook
captures Bishop captures and Bishop
captures on c5 so still our pro has a
knight and the bishop for a rock but
Wesley has this very strong past a pawn
so it's not not all that clear and
another thing that's interesting since
this was a rapid game of Prague niranda
had about 10 seconds on the clock ahead
the time this position was on the board
and moved 36 so Wesley pushes a 4 we
have King to f6 Bishop to e4 now
threatening the h7 point if the knight
ever moves so h6 are removing the target
roped the d5 attacking the bishop
Knight to e6 defending the bishop and
now rook to a5 check King moves and now
Bishop to Bishop to d5 threatening
Bishop captures and then rook captures
Bishop so Bishop to d6 getting the
bishop out of the way a5 now further
pushing the past pawn h3 and now King to
f3 you do have to stop the H pawn of
course we have
h5 and here are all the probable
probably still better here he should
probably wait
but with with so little time on the
clock
there's no time to wait he wants to make
something happen he pushes age 5 and
this of course loses some material we
have bushel captures now comes g4 with
check King to e4 and now King captures
on e6 and now rook captures on H 5 H 2
and now rook to h6 check King to e7
now comes King to d5 Bishop to c7 and
now a six it's okay
Prague has a very strong past H pawn and
the bishop on c7 is guarding it nicely
but the rook can never really leave the
H file as it has to prevent this pawn
from ever reaching H 1 so still a lot of
things can happen here we have King to
f7 now comes a four-star Wesley starts
to push his past EEP on and the e5 o is
definitely a big threat now if he 5 is
pushed then the bishop will no longer be
guarding the h2 pawn and then rook will
be able to capture it we have King to g7
attacking the rook rook to h5 and now
King to g6
again attacking the rook rook to h8 and
here we hear Prager played King to f6 he
prevented Wesley from playing he 5 has
now both Bishop and King are guarding
the e5 square but although this isn't
like this isn't a mistake or anything
but there is a one move that immediately
wins the game for Provo so ok he had a
couple of seconds on the clock so
there's no real way for him to find it
but you know you were comfortable at
home in your own sits in front of your
computer or you know in front of a
smartphone
I feel free to pause the video here and
find the move that wins the game
instantly for black you know give it a
couple of seconds it's not it's not like
a real real simple so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent end game player and
for those of you just want angel so the
move is Bishop to f4
now that you've seen it of course it'll
make sense because now you see that the
threat is better up to h6 simply
blocking the rooks
defense of the H pawn and after Bishop
comes to h6 then h1 wins the game so of
course the black-white would have to
react to this you have to play rook to
h4 not allowing the bishop to block it
but then comes King g5 attacking
rook rook to h8 and now comes g3 this is
the move you had to find to find this
variation sacrificing the pawn pawn
captures Bishop captures and now after
no well it doesn't matter what move
white plays blacks plan is again very
simple rook Bishop is coming to h4
blocking the rooks attack of the h2 pawn
so after any move by white Bishop to h4
is coming and after a couple of checks
you will hide your King and now it's
game over as h1 will win the game but ok
congratulations once again to those of
you who found Bishop to f4 in the game
Prague was very long time he played King
to f6 he prevented e5 King to see if I
was played by Wesley and now King to g5
we have King to d4 and now Prager played
Bishop to b6 check again g3 was winning
because F captures Bishop captures again
we have this idea of Bishop to h4 but
it's a you know a little time on the
clock such blindness can happen Bishop
to b6 check we have King defies special
captures an f2 rook captures and now g3
b defending the bishop attacking the
rook forcing the roof to move back
rook to h8 and now knights the b5 rook
the GH King to f4 rook to f8 check King
to e3 and now II five Wesley again
starts pushing his passport g2 Prague
also pushes his passport and now rook to
g8 attacking the pass pawn king to have
three defending and here as Prague did
have two moments of blindness over the
board here comes a moment of blindness
for Wesley as well as it is a rapid game
King to c6 which would rook captures the
game could have been wrong after Keane
captures a king to c6 is coming and with
which to passed pawns it's it's it's an
easily drawn game but here King to c6
was played and here of course you all
see the move
Wesley missed the bishop to g3 simply
blocking the rooks attack of the pawn he
six was played now comes g1 Queen and
after East 77th was played there's
really nothing more to do here and it
was in this position that Wesley so
resigned the game so a very nice game
anyone okay
it's a nice idea but rook captures Queen
captures and now a7 doesn't work okay it
seems like either pawn after it's pushed
in the air upon will become a queen but
there is this Queen to e5 move still
defending the knight defending the pawn
and everything is fine
after you try anything King D 7 trying
to promote then Queen a5 defending the
knight defending the pawn and after
white does window night then Queen Queen
get Quinn to e8 was simply blocked upon
and all is well so yeah after night to
c7 was the so resigned the game and a
Ramage bauble program and that takes the
lead in this match one to all in the
other game
Wesley so wonder game but it was also a
probably did have a better position but
at some point you know he blundered and
then Wesley took the whole point game
number three was drawn and then Wesley
also won game number four so the match
went to Wesley so what you know it's it
was definitely a beautiful game and a
nice start for for the young Grandmaster
so yeah definitely like I said he was a
less over over a thousand yellow points
higher rated then probably the time this
game was played so the the match and the
two and a half towards one and a half in
Wesley's favor so surely also a nice a
low boost for for young Prabhu so yeah
once again that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and after the game I did the
see on social media while I was you know
enjoying myself on the beach in
Dubrovnik Wesley also invited young
Drago to have dinner with him so also a
very nice nice gesture by Wesley so yeah
I would like to thank Jimmy Steiner
Pietro Marcella Nicholas Miller is a
Clinton and Dobby to find out for a
contribution on my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it more of you
have contributed to my channel while I
was on vacation but my interface allows
only for five of you so I will have to
thank the rest of you in my next video
so yeah as usual you can check to my
previous video so your thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
with a couple of interesting videos and
I think from next Monday we are starting
the Bobby Fischer series yeah I'm
after the game best of luck to England
but of course I hope Croatia will win so
see you soon